désolé, je dois faire un autre
retrait,
ne te retourne pas, je peux t'aider à continuer à
retirer de l'argent, cette mini-fourgonnette à ma gauche
qui est la tienne oui,
juste pour plus de clarté, tu as été
détourné, c'est
vrai, mon enfant est sur le siège arrière,
pistolet oui, reste
ici, c'est gagné  ça ne prend pas longtemps,
viens ta mère, tu ferais mieux de te dépêcher, gamin,
ou ça va mal tourner pour tous les deux.
[Musique]
tu salut, tu
veux voir ta mère, c'est bon, c'est
bon, c'est bon, je suis là, je suis là
bébé, ça  mec, sors un moment, va
à la banque, appelle les flics, donne-leur
ces armes dans la voiture, attends, qui es-tu,
quelqu'un qui préfère ne pas s'impliquer